dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on AFA here this is a
neural network based method that is able
to show us the sound of pixels what this
means is that it separates and localizes
audio signals in videos the two key
words are separation and localization so
let's take a look at these one by one
localization means that we can pick a
pixel in the image and it shows us the
sound that comes from that location and
the separation part means that ideally
we only hear that particular sound
source let's have a look at an example
here's an input video
[Music]
and now let's try to separate the sound
of the cello and see if it knows where
it comes from
[Music]
[Applause]
same with the guitar
now for a trickier question even though
there are sound reverberations of the
walls but the walls don't directly emit
sound themselves so I am hoping to hear
nothing now let's see
flat signal great so how does this work
it is a neural network based solution
that has watched 60 hours of musical
performances to be able to pull this off
and it learns that the change in sound
can often tracked back to a change in
the video footage as a musician is
playing an instrument as a result get
this no supervision is required this
means that we don't need to label this
data or in other words we don't need to
specify how each pixel sounds it learns
to infer all this information from the
video and sound signals by itself this
is huge and otherwise just imagine how
many work hours that would require to
annotate all this data and another cool
application is that if we can separate
these signals then we can also
independently adjust the sound of these
instruments have a look
[Music]
now clearly it is not perfect as some
frequencies may bleed over from one
instrument to the other and there are
also other methods to separate audio
signals but this particular one does not
require any expertise so I see a great
value proposition there if you wish to
create a separate version of a video
clip and use it for karaoke or just
subtract the guitar and play it yourself
I would look no further also you know
the drill this will be way better a
couple papers down the line so what do
you think what possible applications do
you envision for this where could it be
improved let me know below in the
comments thanks for watching and for
your generous support
now see you next time